maintenant on va parler de bigard
maintenant attention là jean marie mais
vous jouez votre site internet
ah oui bah oui www.bing.com foulée
biggar notre libye garneau de sa marche
du feu de dieu
ouais c'est vraiment drôle parce que je
m'aperçois qu'il ya des gens qui
m'aident beaucoup de fric dans des dans
des sites mais qui sont en fait des
nommés qui est qu'ils sont des concepts
et moi je suis pas un concept je suis
une personne et donc les gens
m'appellent je reçois et je reçois une
centaine de mails par jour qui j'ai une
gêne cyber assistante qui a ri qui
répondent à ces super drôle parce que on
lui demande des tas de trucs eux-mêmes
sexuellement comment je suis et où elle
est censée être vraiment ma elle répond
un petit peu ma place et tout est donc
sécurité est ce que dit la vérité elle
dit pas mal la vérité ouais ouais
sexuellement et des bonbons des conseils
à des jeux il ya une boutique wii qu'on
a chez moi je vous dis qu une
photo-montage chaque jour avec une
petite phrase donc chaque jour je suis
en invente quoi louis xiv en suivant pas
prochain il ya une petite phrase qui qui
accompagne on voit le bénisse tous ces
jeux